hey everybody i'm off the grid for
august but msnbc is still a televised
mental institution ellie honestly my
beloved georgia what are the folks doing
out there how is this still a toss-up
because the poll by the atlanta journal
constitution released wednesday
indicates we're not topping walker uh at
46 to 43 with roughly three percent of
voters saying they'll back uh
libertarian candidate chase oliver and
eight percent undecided make it make
sense for me
yeah first of all i just want to thank
the gop for nominating a running back
from dallas to run in georgia and a tv
doctor from new jersey to run in
pennsylvania that's
thank you guys right yeah but yes it's
going to be a close election in georgia
because walker is has the backing of the
republicans now you ask why are
republicans backing this man who's so
clearly unintelligent who so clearly
doesn't have independent thoughts but
that's actually the reason
walker's gonna do what he's told and
that's what republicans like that's what
republicans want from their negroes to
do what they're told and walker presents
exactly as a person who lacks
independent thoughts lacks an
independent agenda lacks an independent
of ability to grasp policies and he's
just gonna go in there and vote like
mitch mcconnell tells him to vote and
remember this has worked for the gop in
the south already tommy tuberville who
right now is probably the dumbest person
in the united states right all he does
is do what mitch mcconnell tells him to
do and so the gop likes these candidates
that aren't able to kind of think for
themselves because that means that it's
just it basically means that mitch
mcconnell gets three votes every time he
shows up to work as opposed to just his
own i do want to just ask you what's
your prediction are we ever going to see
a war warnock walker debate i would pay
top dollar to go ellie to sit front row
at that debate if it ever happened but
your prediction hopefully he won't use
you as a fundraising tool again like he
did before your thoughts
kirsch don't want that smoke hers don't
want that smoke warnock is look let's
also give rafael warnock some credit he
is one of the better politicians that
we've seen come out in the last four
five six years um his ads are on point
his policy positions are on point he's
able to explain this in a way that makes
sense to people from georgia and makes
sense uh to people of you know a more
conservative religious background around
the country like he is he is the real
deal and walker is fake news so i will
they ever debate um that can only hurt
walker and again since walker just does
what he's told if his people tell him
not to debate her osha walker won't have
the wherewithal to overrule them and
take take on that challenge for himself
yeah um well it's renaissance weekend so
i will just say uh herschel walker's
trying to smoke with that yak in his
mouth so we will see what happens if
these two ever meet on the debate stage
thank you as always ellie mcstahl you
are the best ever my friend i love
having you on the show so thanks for
being here